[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihnen allen der
fairanleger in schlütsiil ist
normalerweise alles andere als
Brennpunkt deutscher Politik und
deutschen Zorns mit dem gestrigen Abend
hat sich das geändert als wütende
Landwirte den Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Robert habbeck daran hinderten von Bord
ein affähre zu gehen da wurde es
ungemütlich beleidigend die Polizei
hatte Mühe die Situation im Griff zu
behalten jetzt ist die Diskussion da
nicht nur über die Forderungen der
Bauern die wollen dass die
Bundesregierung ihre Kürzungspläne im
Agrarbereich komplett zurücknimmt halb
eingeknickt ist sie ja schon sondern
auch über die Frage was das war da im
abendlichen schlütsiel an der Küste und
woher diese Aggression kommt Patrizia
Wiedemeier so wurde Robert Harbeck in
seinem Heimatland sicherlich noch nie
empfangen gestern Abend zahlreiche
Bauern waren unterwegs mit ihren
Traktoren zur Anlegestelle schlütsel in
Schleswig-Holstein dort blockierten sie
die Ankunft der Fähre auf der sich
Vizekanzler habbeck befand auf der
Rückfahrt von seinem urlub
die Lage eskalierte habck wurde daran
gehindert auszusteigen die Fähre musste
am Ende wieder ablegen mit dem Minister
am Tag danach parteiübergreifende
Empörung aus meiner Sicht ein vollkommen
inakzeptables Verhalten und diese
Chaoten die dort unterwegs waren haben
dem Anliegen dort wirklich ein bendienst
erwiesen Robert hab hat angeboten dass
er das Gespräch sucht dass sie auf die
Fähre können also diejenige die das da
angeführt haben das haben sie abgelehnt
das war eine Art lünchmob der daich
entsprechend auf dem Weg gemacht hat das
geht gar nicht auch der
Regierungssprecher verurteilte die
Blockade mit deutlichen Worten es sei
beschämend und verstoße gegen die Regeln
des demokratischen Miteinanders es zeigt
dass wir alle aufpassen müssen dass die
politischen Sitten nicht verrohen bei
aller allem Verständnis auch für die
politische
Auseinandersetzung gilt es Regeln zu
beachten und
das ist in diesem Fall
völlig missachtet worden Robert habck
selber äußerte sich heute nur
schriftlich Zitat protestieren ist in
Deutschland ein hohes Gut Nötigung und
Gewalt zerstören dieses Gut in Worten
wie in Taten sollten wir dem
entgegentreten aus dem Innenministerium
in Schleswig-Holstein ist zu hören dass
möglicherweise Rechtsextremisten und
andere extremistische Gruppen mitgemacht
hätten aufgerufen wurde dazu in sozialen
Medien von einem angeblichen
Bürgerdialog mit hab war die Rede man
kennt eigentlich Gewaltbereitschaft beim
bauernprozessen nicht unbedingt aber
seit Anfang der Pandemie herrscht ein
Klima in Deutschland was dazu geführt
hat dass es erstens weniger politische
Vertrauen in die Bundesregierung und in
den Bundestag gibt und dazu kommen noch
in einer umfragestudie die ja letzten
Monat durchgeführt haben dass ist mehr
Gewaltakzeptanz ungefähr 10% der
Menschen in Deutschland denken dass
Gewalt akzeptierbar ist und 15% denken
dass Gewalt von anderen also vor allem
mit politischen Zwecken eigentlich
legitim ist der Bauern Band jedenfalls
distanzierte sich heute man würde nur
friedlich protestieren das ist eine Form
des Protestes die wir und nicht nur die
Verbände sondern auch die Landwirte in
Deutschland so in der Fläche nicht
akzeptieren so kann man nicht
miteinander umgehen der gestrige Abend
ein bitterer Abend für die Regierung für
den Vizekanzler der später mit einer
anderen Fähre dann doch noch am Ziel
ankam bitter vor allem weil die
Regierung gerade gestern einige ihrer
geplanten Kürzungen für die
zurückgenommen
hatte ch östemier ist der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Herr
östemier schön guten Abend guten Abend
das sie was rechnen Sie den jetzt damit
dass das so weitergehen wird wie gestern
an der Fähre dass es auch sie treffen
kann das sollte uns allen eine Lehre
sein zu den Spielregeln in der liberalen
Demokratie gehört dass wir eininander
zuhören dass wirinander ausreden lassen
gelten lassen und vor allem das
wichtigste keine Gewalt in gar keiner
Form und zwar weder von der einen noch
von der anderen Seite so wie wir das bei
der letzten Generation ja auch
verurteilen erwarte ich das jetzt auch
von der von den Kollegen aus der
Opposition von allen
Bauernorganisationen dass es da kein
aber und kein Komma danach gibt so ein
Ausrufezeichen so nicht weil sonst
verrottet hier was und verrutscht hier
was jetzt haben sie gerade schon zwei
Stichworte genannt auf der einen Seite
keine Gewalt auf der anderen Seite
letzte Generation in der kommenden Woche
ist die bundesweite Protestwoche der
Bauern die soll auch weiterlaufen wie
geplant da werden wieder tausende
Traktoren im Einsatz sein es wird auch
mit Blockaden von Straßen gerechnet wo
ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied zu
jemand der sich auf der Straße
anklebt also noch mal wer sich hier
demokratisch organisiert protestiert dem
wird zugehört das ist ja auch passiert
die Beschlüsse haben sich verändert das
haben sie ja mitbekommen ich habe die
auch kritisiert weil ich fand dass das
unsere landwirde landwirde übermäßig
belastet mir sprechen wir gleich noch zu
zu den Inhalten ganz kurz die Frage wenn
ein ein meen treckerverbund Straßen
blockiert wo ist der Unterschied zu
Menschen die sich ankleben ich habe den
Landwirten keine Vorschriften zu machen
aber ich würde allen raten jetzt zu
berücksichtigen wo das gerade landet
dass Leute von ganz rechts außen
versuchen den legitim protester Bauern
für ihre Zwecke zu missbrauchen den
geht's nicht um die deutsche
Landwirtschaft die haben
umsturzfantasien die Landwirte haben
dankenswerterweise große Sympathien in
Deutschland aber das kann man auch
verspielen und diese Bilder von gest
gestern Abend sind dazu angetan dass
sich das jetzt umdrehen kann deshalb
meine Bitte mein Appell sich sehr genau
zu überlegen was man jetzt macht haben
Sie den Eindruck der Bauernverband muss
aufpassen dass er dann nicht
instrumentalisiert und möglicherweise
sogar unterwandert wird also es gibt
massiven Druck von ganz rechts außen die
AFD und auch welche die da im Gewande
der Landwirtschaft daherkommen und wie
gesagt anderes im Schilde führen
versuchenes ich bin sehr dankbar dass
Präsident ruckwit vom Deutschen
Bauernverband das sehr klar ilt hat aber
es scheinen offensichtlich nicht alle zu
schaffen also wenn sie an den
Vorsitzenden des Bauernverbands in
Bayern denken beispielsweise der hat ja
gleich wieder eine Rechtfertigung
hinterher geschoben ich glaube jetzt ist
der Punkt erreicht seit gestern Abend
dass alle sehr genau nachdenken müssen
welche Mittel sie wählen welche Sprache
sie wählen wir müssen wieder
zurückkehren zu dem Stil der sich
bewährt hat für den ich stehe wir setzen
uns zusammen wir lösen die Probleme
gemeinsam am Verhandlungstisch dann
reden wir mal inhaltlich die höheren
Preise für Milch Getreide und so weiter
haben dazu geführt dass der
durchschnittliche Unternehmensgewinn
eines Landwirts im jüngsten
Wirtschaftsjahr um 45% gestiegen ist wie
viel Verständnis sollten denn jetzt all
die anderen bei denen ja auch gekürzt
wird für Landwirte
haben ist ja auch ein Ergebnis unserer
Politik übrigens das will ich auch mal
sagen aber das ist eben eine
Durchschnittszahl das heißt es gibt auch
viele insbesondere tierhalte die mit
existenzzeugen zu tun haben auch den
versuchen wir zu helfen und gute
Lösungen zu finden die beiden Maßnahmen
zusammen KFZ Steuerbefreiung streichen
und dieselprivileg abschaffen waren zu
viel wir haben das korrigiert die KFZ
Steuerbefreiung bleibt weiterhin das
heißt das grüne Kennzeichen für die
Landwirte sehr wichtig für ihre
landwirtschaftlich genutzten Fahrzeuge
bleibt und beim dieselprivileg steigt
man jetzt ja in drei Schritten aus ich
verstehe dass das man immer noch nicht
reicht aber das ist schon eine faere
Maßnahme das will ich mal sagen sie
haben das jetzt korrigiert die
Bundesregierung hat da einen teilweisen
Rück Zug gemacht hat sich da die Macht
der Bauern gezeigt oder die Schwäche
einer Regierung es ist keine Schwäche in
der Demokratie wenn man was korrigiert
weil man merkt dass das in Übermaß
belastet umgekehrt will ich sagen das
ist eine Stärke wenn man zuhört aber was
nicht geht es dass manche jetzt sagen
das reicht uns nicht wir wollen hier
auch Gewalt anwenden wir wollen hier die
Politik unter Druck setzen wir sind
nicht erpressbarum das sehr klar zu
sagen aber es sind ja keine neuen
Argumente und auch keine neuen Daten und
Fakten auf den Tisch gekommen das waren
also jetzt im Rückblick wenig
durchdachte Beschlüsse die die
Bundesregierung rausgehauen hat und die
sie jetzt korrigiert ist denn das gutes
Handwerk ich habe großes Verständnis
dafür dass man unter großem Zeitdruck
versuchen muss den Haushalt
zusammenzuhalten verfassungsgemäßen
Haushalt nach dem Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts in Karlsruhe ich bin
aber auch sehr dankbar dafür dass diese
Beschlüsse jetzt korrigiert wurden das
ist ja auch unterstützt worden durch die
Fraktion durch die Parteien auch will
das noch mal ausdrücken ich sagen den
Teil der Landwirtschaft den die Mehrheit
darstellt die mit demokratischen Mitteln
auf ihre Anliegen hingewiesen haben das
darf wir ja Gott se alles in der
Demokratie jetzt müssen wir allerdings
auch gemeinsam drauf achten dass die
radikalen Ränder nicht stärker werden
Herr
jetzt steht uns eine weitere und ihnen
insbesondere eine weitere Protestwoche
der Bauern in Deutschland bevor ist denn
zu erwarten dass am Ende dieser Woche
die Kürzungspläne komplett gekippt sind
wir haben jetzt ein Kompromiss gefunden
das ist ein guter Kompromiss ein fairer
Kompromiss ist wir verteilen die
Belastungen gleichmäßig überall in der
Gesellschaft ich habe davor gesagt das
war eine übermäßige Belastung das ist
korrigiert worden und jetzt ist auch
Schluss oder haben Sie noch mehr
Möglichkeiten noch weiter auf die
Landwirte zuzugehen nein dann es müsste
gegen finanziert werden ich meine jeder
Haushalt muss gedeckt werden und wir
haben jetzt Deckungen gemacht übrigens
auch aus meinem Bereich ich habe ja auch
einen Beitrag dazu geleistet dass eine
Korrektur möglich war und ich rate jetzt
allen dazu sich das mal vielleicht äh
z und Objektiv zuwerten wird feststellen
dass wir hier sehr fair vorgehen und ich
habe auch den Eindruck dass das das ist
was die Mehrheit der Menschen im Lande
möchten die Dinge müssen mit Maß und
Mitte gemacht werden das machen wir
jetzt und eine Korrektur ist kein Fehler
da fällt einem kein zackenost der Krone
umgekehrt will ich aber noch mal sehr
deutlich sagen wer jetzt glaubt dass er
die Politik erpressen kann wer jetzt
glaubt mit
umsturzfantasien hier irgendwie Eindruck
machen zu können wird sehen dass die
Mehrheit unseres Landes und auch die
Politik da sehr klar steht wir sind
nicht erpressbar sagt der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister J öem
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch und
ihre Zeit heute Abend sehr
gerne und das haben wir aus
Termingründen am Abend
aufgezeichnet den gazaastreifen so wie
er bisher existierte gibt es nicht mehr
fast
70% der Häuser und Wohnungen sind
zerstört oder schwer beschädigt sagt
eine Analyse amanischer
Geheimdienste jeden Tag neue tote von
grausigen Zuständen berichten Mediziner
was das heißt für die Zukunft für fast 2
Millionen Menschen die innerhalb des
schmalen Küstenstreifens auf der Flucht
sind und unter fürchterlichen
Bedingungen irgendwo ausharren das ist
weit weniger klar aus Israel kommen
Konzepte die unterschiedlicher nicht
sein könnten einerseits legt der
Verteidigungsminister jetzt erstmals
einen nachkriegsplan vor andererseits
propagieren der Finanzminister und der
für nationale Sicherheit offen und laut
die Vertreibung der palätinenser aus
Gaza und nennen das zynisch freiwillige
Abwanderung Michael bewerunge aus Tel
Aviv noch ist der Widerstand der Hamas
in Gaza nicht gebrochen das jedenfalls
soll ein Propaganda der
Terrororganisation
zeigen die israelische Armee hält mit
überlegener Waffentechnik dagegen doch
der Krieg gegen die Terroristen trifft
nicht nur die wie das Aufnahmen der
israelischen Armee nahlegen sondern auch
die
Zivilbevölkerung dieser Vater weint um
sein Kind von Israel erwartet er nur das
Schlimmste das sind Kriminelle und die
Mörder von Kindern wir haben mit all dem
nichts zu tun sie ermorden unsere Kinder
und Frauen die israelische Regierung
nimmt Demokratie und
aber
siemenschlich wie sich das demokratische
Israel eine Nachkriegsordnung für Gaza
vorstellen könnte hat
Verteidigungsminister Galland nun
vorgestellt wichtigster Punkt zunächst
komplette Kontrolle durch das
israelische Militär das ein
Wiedererstarken der Hamas verhindern
soll also keine erneute dauerhafte
Besatzung von
Gaza ich denke das ist durchaus
realistischere Israel keine Absicht hat
dort zu bleiben oder dort z.B Siedlungen
wieder aufzubauen oder die direkte
zivile Kontrolle im Gazastreifen zu
übernehmen genau das Schlagen netanahus
rechtsextreme Partner im Kabinett vor
die religiösen Zionisten dauerhafte
Besatzung neue jüdische Siedlungen in
Gaza Umsiedlung von Palästinensern
angeblich auf freiwilliger Basis echte
Chancen hat das aber nicht ich denke
diesene
diese Parteien eine extreme Minderheit
in der israelischen Politik darstellen
ich halte das für überhaupt nicht
realistisch zivile Selbstverwaltung soll
es erstmal nur auf lokaler Ebene geben
mit unbelasteten Palästinensern die
nicht z Hamas gehören wie man das
überprüfen will und ob die
palästinensische Regierung im
Westjordanland eine Rolle spielen soll
bleibt
offen um den Wiederaufbau soll sich eine
internationale Taskforce aus arabischen
staten und lichen Verbündeten
kümmern Deutschland der wichtigste
Partner in Europa reagiert erstmal
zurückhaltend unsere Haltung zum
sogenannten Tag danach ist sehr klar es
darf keine Besetzung des gasastreifens
geben keine Vertreibung und keine
Verkleinerung des
Territoriums zugleich darf für Israel
keine Gefahr aus dem Gazastreifen mehr
ausgehen der Tag danach in Gaza noch ist
vor allem offen wann er denn
kommt so jetzt gucken wir auf wichtige
Entwicklungen für Bahnkunden also für
praktisch uns alle mehr oder weniger
Hanna und das machst du im bisher
festgefahrenen Tarifstreit zwischen
deutscher Bahn und der
lockführergewerkschaft GDL hat die Bahn
ein neues Angebot vorgelegt konkret geht
der Konzern dabei auf eine Kernforderung
der Gewerkschaft ein und will mit einem
wahlmodell eine Absenkung der
Wochenarbeitszeit für Schichtarbeiter
auf 35 Stunden ermöglichen allerdings
ohne den von der GDL geforderten
Lohnausgleich die Gewerkschaft hat sich
dazu bisher nicht geäußert bereits in
der nächsten Woche könnten neue streugs
drohen allerdings offenbar frühestens ab
Mittwoch das berichtet der Kölner
Stadtanzeiger der bisherige
Bundesrichter Jens Rommel soll neuer
general Bundesanwalt werden das hat
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann
mitgeteilt dem Vorschlag muss noch der
Bundesrat zustimmen der 51-Jährige
Rommel ist seit 2020 Richter am
Bundesgerichtshof zuvor leitete er die
zentrale Stelle zur Aufklärung
nationalsozialistischer Verbrechen in
Ludwigsburg Rommel soll auf Peter Frank
Folgen der im Dezember als Richter zum
Bundesverfassungsgericht gewechselt
war bei einem Brand in einem Krankenhaus
in der niedersächsischen Stadt ülsen
sind mindestens fünf Patientinnen und
Patient ums Leben gekommen mehr als ein
Dutzend Menschen wurden laut Polizei
teils schwer verletzt das Feuer war am
späten Donnerstagabend im dritten Stock
der Klinik ausgebrochen Ursache für den
Brand ist noch
unklar bei einem Gottesdienst in der
Stadtkirche von Offenburg haben hunderte
Menschen Abschied von cduptiker Wolfgang
Scheuble genommen neben cduchef märz und
badenwürtbergs Ministerpräsident
Kretschmann würdigte auch schäbles
Tochter Christine das Lebenswerk ihres
Vaters dass er immer wieder mit sein
unbedingter Wille aus dem Leben so wie
es ist etwas zu machen wird immer
Vorbild
bleiben seine Bescheidenheit die
Verpflichtung das Wohl der Gemeinschaft
wichtiger zu nehmen als sein eigenes
Schicksal auch der ehemalige
Parlamentspräsident und Bundesminister
ist am zweiten Weihnachtstag im Alter
von 81 Jahren
gestorben wir alle haben aufgehor ucht
diese Woche als es mitten in einer
bedrohlichen Hochwasserlage in
Deutschland extra Alarm gab und zwar vom
Roten Kreuz und vom Feuerwehrverband die
warten vor massiven Schwächen bei der
Katastrophenvorsorge sie prangerten
eklatante Defizite an besonders bei der
materiellen Ausstattung und das in einem
Land das ja eigentlich gelernt haben
sollte aus Katastrophen wie im Aartal
und dass zumindest für den Schutz vor
Katastrophen genug Geld aufzubringen in
der Lage sein
sollte was ist also dran an diesen
Klagen wo stehen wir aktuell wir haben
unsere Reporterin Svenja Domeier
losgeschickt in
Niedersachsen sie schleppen Sandsäcke
Arbeiten unter extremen Bedingungen
manchmal Tag und Nacht seit fast zwei
Wochen sind die freiwilligen Helfer die
Stütze der hochwasserbekämpfung das ist
unglaublich was alle Leisten also
überall sind kommen junge Leute oder
Leute vom THW vom dhlg von den
Freiwilligen Feuerwehren und
unterstützen uns rund 1,7 Millionen
ehrenamtliche Helfer bilden das
Fundament des Bevölkerungsschutzes in
Deutschland mit mehr als eine Million
Mitgliedern kommt die größte Gruppe der
freiwilligen von den
Feuerwehren es gibt in jedem Dorf in
jeder Gemeinde eine Feuerwehr das gibt
es nur in Deutschland und in Österreich
da sind wir stolz drauf und wenn wir das
nicht hätten dann hätten wir diese
Hochwasserlage wie sie jetzt in
Norddeutschland ist nie in den Griff
bekommen personell läuft es also ein
Problem die dieser Tage aber marode
Deiche jahrelang sei zu wenig investiert
worden bemängeln Experten wir werden
mehr extreme haben und wir müssen un da
dran anpassen oft ist man dort besser
aufgestellt wo auch in letzter Zeit
Hochwasser waren insgesamt wird schon
einiges getan aber wir sind längst nicht
da wo wir hin müssen auch bei der
Ausrüstung der Hilfskräfte gibt es
Erneuerungsbedarf das bundeseigene
Technische Hilfswerk hatte vom Corona
Konjunkturpaket profitiert und sieht
sich heute gut aufgestellt das Deutsche
Rote Kreuz aber und der Feuerwehrverband
fordern dringend mehr Geld wir müssen
hier nachbessern wir müssen nicht nur
für das Hochwasser nachbessern wir
müssen natürlich auch für alle folgenes
Klimawandels nachbessern und hier ist
auch Nachholbedarf es gibt eine
Forderung der Innenminister aus dem
letzten Jahr das 10 Milliarden Euro für
den Bevölkerungsschutz zur Verfügung
gestellt werden müssen aus Bundes und
Landesmittel das kann ich nur
unterstreichen und das ist auch
notwendig gelernt habe man bislang vor
allem aus der Flutkatastrophe im Sommer
2021 ein Kompetenzzentrum Bevölkerung
Schutz wurde danach eingerichtet Risiken
sollen hier mit allen Beteiligten
analysiert Krisenmanagement stetig
verbessert werden auf der anderen Seite
haben wir natürlich die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Bund und Ländern verstärkt sie
ist besser geworden vertrauensvoller
geworden wir tauschen uns häufiger und
besser aus der Ruf nach einem
verbesserten Katastrophenschutz schalt
in der Hochwasserlage wieder laut
Besuche von Spitzenpolitikern gehören
zum Programm wirken aber selten
nachhaltig
das Hauptproblem des
Katastrophenschutzes ist nach wie vor
die Kurzatmigkeit das heißt s haben
jetzt sehr viele Bilder von
Katastrophentourismus aus Berlin und um
da im Bild zu bleiben nach den Strömen
an Touristen bleiben meistens die
Finanzströme aus so soll es eigentlich
nicht sein das ist ein Thema was man
langfristig im Kopf behalten muss sowohl
im Katastrophenfall als auch dann wenn
die Katastrophe mal nicht eintreten die
Einsatzkräfte werden weiter anpacken bis
das Wasser endlich zurückgeht und hoffen
dass die Investitionen in besseren
Schutz am Ende nicht wieder ins Wasser
und jetzt an dieser Stelle in der
Sendung noch mal du Hanna ja mit einem
Blick auf den deutschen Einzelhandel
dort ist die Stimmung ja schon länger
nicht die beste und auch das wichtige
Weihnachtsgeschäft lief anders als
gewünscht Frank betmann nun gibt's die
Umsatzzahlen für 2023 wie sehen die aus
na ja die passen zur Stimmung die
Umsätze im vergangenen Jahr sind nur
leicht gestiegen und das auch nur weil
die Preise so nach oben geschossen sind
rechnet man die teuung raus zeigt sich
das wahre Bild preisbereinigt sind die
Umsätze nämlich sogar zurückgegangen
besonders starke Einbußen verzeichneten
lebensmittelfachgeschäfte wie Bäckereien
oder Metzgereien sowie Läden für
Einrichtungsgegenstände Haushaltsgeräte
und Baubedarf selbst der während Corona
boomende Internet und Versandhandel war
2023 im Vergleich zum Vorjahreszeitraum
real rückläufig bei den Zahlen sprechen
wir zwar von nur vorläufigen Schätzungen
doch schon jetzt ist klar das war kein
gutes Jahr für den Einzelhandel gibt es
denn irgendeine Hoffnung dass 2024
besser wird die gibt es gerechnet wird
damit dass die Löhne steigen und
gleichzeitig die Inflation deutlich
zurückgeht das würde bedeuten dass sich
die Menschen wieder mehr leisten könnten
doch ob es auch so kommt und ob sie das
Geld dann auch wirklich voll in den
Konsum stecken das ist die große
Unbekannte bei diesen Gedanken spielen
vielen Dank Frank für diese
Einschätzung einen Tag vor dem Finale
der 72 vierschanzenournee in
Bischofshofen ist Andreas Wellinger in
der Qualifikation mit 128 m auf dem
neunten Platz gelandet und damit weit
hinter dem tneeführenden Japaner
Kobayashi der mit 138 m erster wurde
Wellinger belegt derzeit Platz 2 in der
Gesamtwertung sollte der 28-Jährige
morgen gewinnen wäre es der erste
deutsche Triumph seit dem Sieg von Sven
hannerwald
die deutschen Biathletinnen und
Biathleten haben sich beim Weltcup
Auftakt in Oberhof zwei podestplatze
gesichert benedikctt doll holte beim
Sprint über 10 km seinen sechsten
Weltcupsieg er war 1,8 Sekunden
schneller als der Norweger lergrade
seine Kollegin Franziska Preu sprintete
auf Platz 2 nach 7,5 km lag sie nur 4,4
Sekunden hinter der Französin RA
bouch
der Unternehmer Günther Fielmann ist tot
der Gründer der gleichnamigen
Optikerkette starb am Mittwoch im Alter
von 84 Jahren in seinem Wohnort
lötchensee in Schleswig-Holstein der
Augenoptiker eröffnete
1972 seine erste Filiale heute sind es
mehr als 1000 mit rund 23 000
Beschäftigten die Optiker Branche prägte
er mit modischen Modellen zu günstigen
Preisen 2019 übergab er die Führung an
seinen Sohn mag darüber hinaus
engagierte vielmann sich als
ökolandwirt Liebe ist etwas wunderbares
wirklich große Liebe zu erfahren und zu
geben wohl das beste was uns Menschen
überhaupt passieren kann alle die lieben
werden da jetzt heftig nicken und
selbstverständlich gilt es auch für
Politikerin und Politiker an denen man
manches kritisieren kann aber nicht dass
sie einen lauen Job hätten im
Scheinwerferlicht der Öffentlichkeit
zwischen Wahlkreis und Amt zwischen
Krisensitzung und Bürgersprechstunde
bleibt häufig kaum Zeit für
Privates und so kommt dann eins zum
anderen Mann Frau verliebt sich im Job
oder in jemanden mit demselben Job und
plötzlich kommen zum großen Glück
drängende Fragen was das nämlich heißt
für die Arbeit für die heikle
öffentliche Beziehung jenseits der
privaten wir beim Regierenden
Bürgermeister von Berlin wären Kai
Wegner CDU hat heute das öffentlich
gemacht über was in Berlins Politik
schon länger geredet wird er ist
zusammen mit Katharina Günther wünsch
CDU der Bildungssenatorin Markus groß
Ksten Berent und Roman leskowa
berichten es ist Liebe berlins
Regierender Bürgermeister und die
bildungssenatoren offiziell ein Paar
beim neujahrsfang der Charlottenburg
Wilmersdorf heute Abend waren beide
abwesend und doch Topthema bei der
Parteibasis ich würde grundsätzlich
sagen dass gehört erstmal nur im
privaten Bereich und hat auch erstmal
dann von außen nicht zu beurteilt zu
werden aber natürlich bleibt ein
geschmckler und in jeder Behörde wird da
kritisch geguckt wenn der Vorgesetzte
was mit der Untergebenen hat es hätte
vorher kommuniziert werden müssen
erheblich
früher Berlin früher aber
Sex
K und K in
Love doch behindert Liebe die
senatsarbeit fragt die Opposition wie
geht man damit um wenn es z.B Konflikte
zwischen senatsmitgliedern gibt kann der
regierende dann von seiner Richtlinien
Kompetenz Gebrauch machen oder ist er
befangen wie geht man um mit Kürzungen
im Haushalt wird dann die
bildungssenatoren ausgenommen oder
gerade nicht es gibt viele Fragen die
sich stellen Liebe in der Spitzenpolitik
gibt's schon britter ernst und Olaf
Scholz Oscar lafontain und Sarah
Wagenknecht doch Katharina Günther
wünsch und Kai Wegner sind als Paar in
einer Landesregierung der Bürgermeister
gegenüber den Senatoren weisungsbefugt
also die Frage ist so eine Beziehung an
sich justiziabel da kann man relativ
deutlich sagen nein äh man kann relativ
schlecht vorschreiben wo die Liebe
hinfällt es ist eine S mal ethisch
moralische Thematik weil natürlich bei
allen anderen immer das Problem
mitschwingt die sind in einer Beziehung
äh gibt es da möglicherweise irgendwo
vor Teile die möglicherweise gewert
vielleicht auch nicht man weiß es nicht
aber der Anschein reicht ja schon der
vermittelt wird und andersrum ist
natürlich auch die Senatorin nicht so
schön weil sie wird natürlich besonders
kritisch beeugt der Koalitionspartner
Berlins SPD wollte sich nicht äußern zur
senatsromanze die schon lange ein
Gerücht war ein Foto aus dem Mai letzten
Jahres beide sehr nah doch erst seit
Oktober sein sie ein Paar hat Wegner
heute schriftlich wieer Anwalt mitteilen
lassen Arbeit und Liebe können wir tren
sagt Wegner und äußert sich heute
ausschließlich im Radio unromantisch
knapp da ist nicht mehr zu sagen weil es
eine private Sache ist und von daher ist
das
so die Liebe im Roten Rathaus eine
private
Sache diese Beziehung wird unter
Beobachtung stehen sie wird unter Druck
stehen und sie könnte zum Problem
werden
so uns beiden bleibt jetzt noch Ihnen
einen schönen Abend zu wünschen wir
sehen uns morgen wieder tschüss
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend das Tief das den
Alpen eine Neuschneeauflage beschert
zieht bis Sonntagabend weiter ostwärts
und dann wird für uns dieses hoch
interessant denn das bringt deutlich
tiefere Temperaturen mit und dann wird
es von Norden auch merärklich sonniger
schauen wir es uns der Reihe nach an das
Tief brigittter das heute von Westen
herankam das zieht im Laufe der Nacht
etwas weiter Richtung Südosten und sie
sollten sich nach wie vor auf
gefährliche straßenblätter einstellen
durch Schneefall in Hamburg scheswig-
Holstein und in mecklburg Vorpommern und
auch aus den Alpen heraus fällt Schnee
am ehesten trocken bleibt es in dieser
Nacht hier noch so zwischen der neie und
der Mosel und das bei Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 4° am Rhein und -2° nordöstlich
der Elbe die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen in der ckermark um -1° sonst wird
etwas milder besonders am Mittel und am
oberrein mit 6° und das tiefri Gitter
das zieht morgen über Tag weiter
südwärts gleichzeitig kommen aber diese
schneefäler aus den Alpen heraus weiter
nach Norden erreichen dann auch die
schwäbische Alp München und den
Bayerischen Wald auch in Norddeutschland
bleibt es zum Teil noch glatt am ehesten
trocken wird es dann morgen übertag so
zwischen Sachsen und dem Saarland sein
und auch am Sonntag fällt noch Schnee in
Süddeutschland dann aber wird es von
Norden doch immer sonniger und kälter am
Dienstag liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
bei -7 bis + 2° schönes
Wochenende